[Music]
hey what's up ann in richmond virginia
and how in the world are you
i'm gay how are you good i know you can
hear us talking when we're not on air
and i'm you can tell i'm not i'm not
very good at this um
you also owe kelly a lot of money
because you've said listen so far twice
so oh come on kelly wasn't even paying
attention
real cool ann
you were
you were that kid in school they were
like can we just do more homework
then probably oh gosh darren's looking
at my paper thanks anne the world needs
the world needs more ads
my sister and i have like always been
pretty close
um we got married around the same time
and then the
two of us couples were really close
and
now they're getting a divorce and
we're just trying to figure out like how
to navigate this and how they managed to
stay friends and keep things sort of
normal for all of our kids and
what do we do
so is everything man that messes up
weekends evenings babysitting
hey we're gonna yeah
and then you all have like um
the same gang of friends too outside of
your little family bubble oh gosh
okay so why are they getting divorced is
there any any like abuse or
um
evil stuff going on or do they just fall
out of love and blah blah blah
i think it's mostly
the just
they grew apart or she grew up and he's
kind of the same person he's always been
and
i don't think
i don't see it as he's a bad person
as much as they just don't see eye to
eye and also
he
he can be a little bit on the
controlling side when things aren't the
way he thinks they ought to be he just
wants people to like to try to buckle
down and
[Music]
come i don't know
try harder for his way rather than
compromise and so i don't see it as
abuse but definitely not healthy either
okay and i said something that i hate i
actually i said did they just fall out
of love i don't i don't really think
that happens i think people just quit
working on it so it sounds like they
over time just stopped working on stuff
right
and that's the way i see it okay all
right i mean i haven't been i haven't
been there you know 24 7 so i you know
that's right so i can't say 100
here's a couple of things
it really is going to come down to how
mature everybody wants to be
and
so the first thing i want you to be
cognizant of and put on the table in
your home with your husband
is this wilson shockwave through your
marriage
it will send shockwaves through you
through your husband and through y'all's
through your connection
right three and he'll it can be a
oh we can just get out of this thing or
i don't want that to happen to us or now
it's become real like oh this can happen
right everybody kind of trips out a
little bit there's grieving that has to
happen on yalzon
and if y'all haven't gone out one night
or one morning and just said
this is gonna affect us
how are we
then you gotta do that because there's
gonna be a lot of unspoken stuff
um yeah how similar or am i right has
this happened
um to some extent and then i feel like i
feel like we're gonna you know like
we've realized that things are
it could happen but things are you know
we talk more and like i don't know it's
like we're in a good spot right now cool
you know
nothing nothing could happen but
there you go so i want you all to look
at this as a chance to
reimagine where y'all are
headed and where y'all are right now
and make this fun if you can get away
for a weekend on how how old your kids
are but if you don't get away for a
weekend if you can get away for an
afternoon or an evening do that and make
this so fun
so fun and it doesn't have to be a oh no
we don't want to become them i think you
got to put that on the table and say hey
this is
this is just sucks and this is scary and
this is and
um where do we want to go what is next
two years three years seven years gonna
look like for us we don't know what the
world's gonna look like but who are we
gonna be in the midst of all the mayhem
and um yeah i think that's so good so
when it comes to friends and
relationships and family and this kind
of stuff if there's abuse
like if he was beating up your sister
there's some
relationships like we're we're we're
cutting people off right uh there's
child abuse like you're not gonna be
around my kids you're not gonna be
around my home etc
my again my friends we've been together
for so long but we're really open about
this stuff
and so
back when one night we were all just
hanging out a couple of my oldest
buddies somebody just said it out loud
like hey by the way if any of us ever
get divorced
i'll love y'all but your wife is welcome
to come stay at my house
like no questions asked right
so i think it would be really wise and
very mature and grown up of you
to if they can be in the same room if
you all can still sit in the same room
together
then to invite them over for dinner and
say
we're still having all the kids together
y'all two can do your thing but i'm
still gonna call him i'm still gonna
call you
and the two husbands are still gonna go
hang out and go do whatever they do and
me and you are gonna that's still gonna
happen and we're not gonna pick sides
here
and we're not gonna get drawn into any
drama and oh why didn't you respond to
my text you respond i heard i hear
you're talking to him
i think just calling that out
putting it on the table you all have
chosen to not be married we are choosing
to still love both of you does that make
sense
yeah and we've tried that and now we're
getting some pushback and like why do
you spend time with him and
hey just there you go so here's what you
did you put a boundary on the table and
your boundary was we're gonna love you
both
and now they're gonna people are gonna
bang their head up against the boundary
and see if it's real and so this is when
you respond back and say hey i'm not
doing this i love you
and if you're gonna tell me that to be a
sister who loves you it means i have to
cut off friends
um i'm not gonna do that or maybe you
say okay i'll do that and you tell him
hey i've got it i love you but i gotta
side with my sister on this one
and you're gonna need to find your own
gang right if you all want to do that
then so be it and when it comes to the
other friends i think you let them know
we're still going bowling or i don't
know what you guys your friends do
together
like
we're still going to go do those things
we're going to invite everybody
y'all to you can decide because you all
made a grown-up decision you all too can
decide
and here's the other thing that's going
to just
just is a grenade in the middle of
everything
is everything's gonna be different now
it's gonna be weird there's gonna be
that awkward fleshing out part and the
uh it's just gonna be weird there's not
gonna be a when do we get back to normal
because there's gonna have to be a new
normal and you all get to design what
this new normal is gonna look like but
it's gonna be annoying and frustrating
and it's okay to be so mad at your
sister for screwing everything up and
it's gonna be fine to be mad at this
dude um her ex for screwing everything
up and partridge in a pear tree but
holidays are gonna look different
thanksgiving christmas it's all gonna
look different right
yeah it's as intentional as possible and
then just don't put up with people
acting like children i i thought you
were going to be my friend more and stop
we're not doing that right yeah
okay
how much is that happening or are you
imagining it happening
um
recently it has been happening because
basically just
like just the way circumstances where we
were hanging out with her more and then
we got invited to some stuff with him
and then and other friends fell together
and now she's upset about that and like
it's not about him it's like the whole
group of friends and
we wanted to do this and now she's like
not happy
yeah so in her grief
and in her shame and in her frustration
and in her anger
she's gonna have to find repeated
scapegoats
and as her best friend and sister and
also as the adult in the room
you are going to be the brunt of this
unfortunately that's where you just
calling her out like dude i love you
stop this stop
stop your child
and this is gonna be heartbreaking for
you
but if she chooses to act like a child
and disconnect from you because you're
acting like a grown-up
that may be part of what's next for you
for a while i don't think it will be
forever but that may be what's coming up
does that make sense
that's heartbreaking i know but here's
the thing when we love people
people just do dumb things they do
stupid things they do things differently
than we do and they do things that
frustrate us they do things that are
incredible they win the lottery and then
suddenly he's like oh what happened
that's just part of loving people it's a
risk and it's hard and that's when you
have to know who your gang is what your
values are what your boundaries are
and then how you're going to speak him
into the world
and i hope your sister will love you and
go i know i know
and that's when you as her that's when a
sister who loves her can say do you
really think i don't love you stop
and we're going to go hang out with
friends and if you don't want to come
because you divorce this guy that's your
choice congratulations but we're going
bowling because we love bowling and i'll
still come over your house but we're not
going to keep a tally how many times do
with him or with me and by the way he'll
get remarried someday
and um feels like most guys it'll be
about two and a half weeks from now
he'll
run into some old middle school
girlfriend and just call it
and um he'll end up making his own life
so some of this is going to be temporary
and then you and your sister will stay
connected at some point so
um some of this is just getting through
the discomfort of where we are right now
ugh so frustrating but you and your
husband y'all be the adults in the room
hold your boundaries and take care of
those little kids make sure they're all
hanging out together